[Musica]
gli sto dei rifiuti rispiegato a me ciao
a tutti mi chiamo gaia e o 9 anni sono
una bambina molto curiosa bene la mia
mamma da futurista si ragazzi dico sul
serio
anch'io non lo so molto bene come si fa
a lavorare con in futuro e fare ricerche
con qualcosa che non esiste ancora ma
mamma sei una specie di archeologa di
futuri mamma cosa significa gli studi di
futuri e il foresight e come sonori i
laboratori di futuri e perché parlate
futuri e non futuro ma siete futuristi
come depero e marinetti
mi puoi spiegare cosa significa vanno
[Musica]
dai e mia figlia e come tanti bambini
bambini di quest'età le file ma media di
200 domande al giorno
a volte mi sembra che lavora un'agenzia
di comunicazione gli utilizzi spesso la
regola delle 5 w
ma chi quando come perché dove in altre
occasioni
le domande sono grandi questioni
esistenziali alla quale ovviamente non
mi sento in grado di rispondere
sappiamo che facendo domande i bambini
costruiscono la propria immagine del
mondo io fondamentale che loro possano
imparare a leggerlo a rota a leggere il
mondo per conoscerlo trasformarlo e così
diventare esploratori di futuri i
protagonisti del proprio viaggio nel
tempo infatti ci sono argomenti degli
argomenti che ispirano
ed emozioni più di altri come il futuro
e il tempo frequentemente gae mi chiede
ma da dove viene il futuro
da quando mie figlie iniziato a capire
che la mamma lavora con qualcosa che non
esiste ancora subitamente ha deciso di
fare un podcast per spiegare ai suoi
compagni cosa significa lavorare con il
futuro e per poter decodificare anche
lele professione come foresight
strategist futurista professionale
critico in speculativi designer e tante
altre mansione che hanno come comune
denominatore la visione prospettica e
come oggetto di lavori il futuro allora
quando lei ha iniziato a fare questo
podcast ho preso ho colto al volo
l'opportunità di spiegare anche alle
adulti non addetti al lavoro spesso le
persone mi chiedo ma cosa fai un
futurista e no non siamo futuristi come
ballad e per i marinetti e gli studi di
futuri non c'entrano assolutamente nulla
con il futurismo movimento artistico e
culturale dell'inizio del secolo scorso
e vedo un altri spoiler non c'è bisogno
di improbabili capacità divinatoria e
tutti noi siamo in grado di acquisire
gli skills per disegnare scenari di
futuri bene dunque prima raccontarvi
cosa fa un ricercatore una ricercatrice
i cicli stradis devo dirvi cosa non fa
un futurista noi non prevediamo il
futuro per il semplice fatto che il
futuro non esiste in futuro non adatti e
anche se volessimo tentare di prevederlo
non avremmo mai a disposizione tutte le
informazioni per poter contemplare con i
variabili in gioco soprattutto in un
mondo volate le incerto complesso e
ambiguo come
nostro comunque sappiamo che le scelte
che compiamo oggi corrispondono a un
alternativa e di futuro possibile in
altre parole le nostre azioni o non
azione producono sempre con sequenze
quello che possiamo fare imparare
anticipare e anticipare i cambiamenti
attraverso metodi strumenti o
identificanti identificando i segnali
deboli che sono quei pezzetti di futuri
che appaiono nel presente
ricordando ci saranno sempre 20 fuori
dalle nostre rather 20 impossibili da
anticipare i detti cini neri come per
esempio l'attacco alle torri gemelle o
la bolla tecnologica dell'inizio del
millennio o quest'ultimo che di grandi
impatti mi piace tantissimo che la moda
dell'estate 2020 sarebbe stato il la
mascherina portata al vomito possibile
anticipare ok ma perché diciamo futuri e
non futuro allora questo campo di
ricerca multidisciplinari detto gli
studi di futuri nato dopo la guerra
fredda industriale militare si chiama
così perché il futuro è plurale
non c'è quindi non ci può essere uno
solo futuro bensì un infinità di
potenziali futuri possibili possibili
preferibile auspicabili gli confessa che
da quando interiorizzate questi concetti
trent'anni fa che il futuro non è
lineare che il futuro è un insieme di
realtà alternativa chi potrebbero
accadere tutto è cambiato
io racconto haga è che è stata una sorta
di power man quando ci rendiamo conto di
questo super potere
diventiamo consapevoli delle
potenzialità creativa che abbiamo a
nostra disposizione e che ci permette di
assumere la qualità di protagonista
almeno in parte di quello che avviene e
avverrà intorno a noi
e così cambiare il nostro rapporto con
il futuro
sì posso dire che sono un arco olga di
futuri allo stesso modo in cui
l'archeologo e studia le civilità le
culture del passato e le relazioni con
ambienti circostanti
no ai futuristi studiamo le relazioni
tra persone società cultura tecnologia
economia ambienti politica dal futuro al
deal è vero ho detto a lei che sono una
crononauta in cui la definizione colui o
colei chi viaggia nel tempo e molto piu
q e se ci pensiamo bene anche gli
archeologi storici viaggiano nel tempo
però no ai futuristi prendiamo un altro
e direzione praticamente questo che
faccio viaggi gli strategici nel tempo
portale personale scuole aziende
comunità ad esplorare orizzonti di medio
lungo termine
per avere un'idea di quale frey
zeitgeist lo spirito del tempo tra 15 20
30 anni dopo torniamo al presente ed
elaboriamo e strategie per riparare il
futuro più desiderato oppure disegniamo
diversi scenari di futuri per viaggiare
parallelamente del tempo
in realtà quando ghaemi chiede dov'è la
mia macchina del tempo racconto chi per
ora è un viaggio mentale nel tempo le
marche le macchine sono i nostri
cervelli in un esercizio di futuro più
le macchine sono diverse tra loro più
sofisticati
atti di 20 scenari di futuri
ovviamente vuole diventare una crono a
nauta anche lei per pensare
l'impensabile
una cosa è certa se non siamo noi a
costruire a pensare i nostri futuri
qualcuno lo farà al posto nostro
la nostra grande sfida e uscire dalla
gabbia del presente è stato lo storico
francese françois hartog a coniare il
termine presentismo proprio per dar
conto di questo rapporto che la società
occidentale è instaurato con il tempo il
presente onnipresente la ossessione per
la presenza il presentismo è una specie
di the futuri d'azione cioè la
sensazione di non avere un domani e per
superare questo ostacolo
abbiamo bisogno di una di una competenza
di una capacità di aspirare
un'alfabetizzazione ai futuri è proprio
così chi chiamava chiamiamo lazio
sleepers i love and bass nei futuri
la capacità di usare il futuro nel
presente in contesti diversi con i
processi i scopi diversi
alfabetizzazione i futuri e interessante
percepire il potenziale di questo
termine perché ogni nuovi termini poi
aiutarci a costruire nuovi mondi e se
siamo consapevoli che è possibile
hackerare i nostri futuri possiamo
trasformare le nostre narrativa di
futuri in cambiamento nel presente
alfabetizzazione i futuri
alfabetizzazione è molto di più che
leggere e scrivere il teorico
dell'educazione paolo freri sosteneva il
processo di alfabetizzazione come
mezzo di emancipazione civili e libertà
lui ha suscitato nelle persone la
convinzione che è possibile cambiare il
mondo è esattamente questo scopo
dell'alfabeto e dell'apprendimento ai
futuri se impariamo anticipare possiamo
cambiare il mondo che verrà
immaginare è un atto di bo missionario
la creatività poi il tar ha il pace
storari svariati modi di essere nel
mondo e tutti noi abbiamo visioni dei
futuri le nostre visioni ci ispirano ma
possono anche limitarci se sentiamo
sempre le stesse narrazioni di futuri
infatti la cosa più pericolosa quando
parliamo di futuri sono le narrazioni
uniche i futuri devono essere inclusivi
de coloniali ide colonizzati
e adesso vi spiego per bene cosa
significa futuri colonizzati da sempre
l'elite inteso come gruppi di potere
tentano di manipolare scena
ridicolizzare i futuri per imporre la
loro visione di mondo cioè quello che
gli conviene perché il futuro prima di
essere un tempo e uno spazio e come tale
è possibile occuparlo è una nostra
responsabilità non lasciare che i nostri
futuri vengono occupati da altri
qualsiasi scenario di future per il bene
comune deve permettere tutte le persone
di guardarci dentro tutte le persone in
particolare quelle che non sono abituate
a vedersi riflesse nei processi
decisionali
se non s don e minoranze etniche
culturali come comunità lgbt chi è a
classi lavoratrici persone con
disabilità
tutti hanno lo stesso diritto
tanto quanto le élite di decidere loro
ruolo nel futuro collettivo il nostro
roll
basta quei futuri colonizzati dobbiamo
coltivare la nostra capacità di aspirare
perché anticipare è anche resistere
grazie grazie
gaia vieni gajan grazie
[Applauso]